even before you see what has happened  here you can smell it the ash blowing  through the air the trees that are still  smoking  it is a stark  sobering sight this trail of devastation  wrought  by this fire a charred car park of quad  bikes and sports cars and pickup trucks  all completely destroyed you imagine  that at one stage this was quite  colorful colorful vehicles green trees  but now it's black and gray it's all  monochrome and if you need a sense of  quite how hot it must have been at the  heart of the fire just look at this  trail of what at some point must have  been a molten metal coming from a  charred bicycle  this part of the fire is now under  control even though we still can see  some flames we can still see smoke of  course firefighters have now moved on to  far bigger blazes which continue to move  through thousands of acres of land